je reçois maintenant jean vautrin
jean vautrin bonsoir c'est tout le monde
alors votre vrai nom c'est jean herment
nom sous lequel vous avez été dans une
première vie cinéastes puisque vous avez
fait jeff adieu l'ami et vous avez écrit
le scénario de garde à vue césar 1980 du
meilleur scénario si vous êtes devenu
jean vautrin hauteur de 33 ans dont le
goncourt 89 pour un grand pas vers le
bon dieu sans compter les bd avec dan
franck et a publié aujourd'hui le
journal de luis béchir robert laffont je
vais faire le pitch donc c'est
l'histoire d'une prof violé par ses
élèves lors d'une tournante
les bourgeois de la ville essaie
d'acheter son silence pour ne pas
compromettre l'avenir des quelques fils
de famille auteur des faits mais elle
refuse elle refuse tout marchandage
et elle devient une tueuse schizophrène
oui moi je dirais plutôt que les psig
logiquement détruite complètement et que
dans cette fable sur la violence je
raconte l'histoire d'une fille qui est
blessé qui est incapable de se
restructurer et qui accueille dans sa
propre personnalité une invitée elle
s'appelle louisa d'arc ans de son vrai
nom est l avant qu une droite parallèle
une espèce de guerrière qui s'appelle
luis luis b et qui va finalement assumé
la situation pour elle autrement dit
elle se réfugie dans un monde virtuel
est elle effectivement schizophrène et à
partir de l'a77 louise b va se jeter à
la tête des hommes ce qu'elles n'osent
pas faire affronter les corses que
n'osent pas faire évader éventuellement
devenir une tueuse c'est vrai sans
remords et sans larmes s'est inspiré
d'un fait divers bien réelle avait
inspiré d'un fait réel une une prof
quelque part dans la vienne se fait
vieux rhin et par ses élèves de 3e dans
la première phrase du livre est notable
elle possède pour tout guide l'élan de
son immense dégoût et on va suivre sa
chute dans une société qui s'effondre et
dans un monde ça qui s'écroule vous êtes
moi je crois que c'est surtout ça le
thème du livre c
c'est le naufrage de bien des coeurs et
de bien des esprits qui sont conduits à
la marge d'une société complètement
inhumaines les sociétés assourdis par le
fric avec déjà se presser une grande
indifférence et être rejetée à la marge
ça veut dire principalement avoir
recours à la violence pour s'en sortir
peut-être en tout cas c'est le cas de
bien des gens je regardais l'autre jour
un moule à la télé qui essayait de dire
je t'aime à une fille qui n'avait pas
les mots pour le dire et getti place
était un violeur en puissance ça peut ça
vous décrivez très bien le monde actuel
je veux dire un petit passage elle avait
allumé la radio une voix transit stories
et l'avait aussitôt renseigner sur
l'avancement du genre humain on étrangle
est à l'autre bout du monde en afrique
en tchétchénie on tue les ont égorgés
enseignants éclaté au moyen-orient les
bombes fragmenter les chats écroulé
les commandos nettoyer 2000 oiseaux
nager dans le brut
la banquise se fracturait et la terre se
couvraient des buissons d'épineux s'est
dit gentiment et sans sarcasme
c'était la voix des médias chez nous ça
vers moule est assez bien curetage de
cerveau love story fabriquer
tranquillement son contingent de moules
la bazoge grimper au mât des affaires
les potages tuer leurs copains à coups
de batte de baseball les hommes
politiques avaient le revolver sur la
tempe
bon on en a plein d'un côté de rire vous
avez raison de maintenir le rire mais je
trouve c'est formidable il faut à toute
force continuer à rire et à se moquer
des choses mais moi j'ai choisi une
autre voie quoi hein j'ai choisi une
espèce d'expressionnisme par rapport à
mon époque mais c'est pas nouveau a
depuis les années 70 je sculpte la
société ceci a plaidé au polar dans le
temps on avait parlé des hlm
vous avez ri au nez puis c'est vrai que
c'était des cages à lapins et moi j'ai
pas cessé de discuter la société de
raconter ça alors
j'ai pas parcours très orthodoxe mais
j'en suis assez fier vous raconter très
bien le chaos et la barbarie du web
actuel en tous les cas vous dites
vous-même d'ailleurs un style dégraisser
jusqu'à l'os ouais je crois que j'ai
exprimée le plus possible avec le moins
de mots possibles minimale moi je crois
que ce qui compte pour moi effectivement
c'est le style c'est la façon de
raconter une histoire je suis le
contraire de nombriliste j'ai envie de
raconter des histoires j'ai envie de
raconter des personnages j'ai envie de
raconter l'univers dans lequel je vis
j'ai envie de m'insurger contre lui et
j'ai encore en plus cette espèce de
velléités de mai raillé en me disant que
les écrivains du 21e siècle ont
peut-être pour tâche d'être des
pamphlétaires à une époque où la presse
le fait plus voilà plus pas suffisamment
où il ya plus de jours de pignons où il
ya plus de pamphlétaire précisément sauf
quelques humoristes comme ça bon
béquille qui font au jour le jour qui
donc ram quelquefois ils n'arrivent pas
à l'excellence parce que ils n'ont pas
le temps d'avoir des paliers de
réflexion comme nous les écrivains on a
un
alors l'écriture vous avez le temps vous
considérez ça vraiment comme un
artisanat un commun comme un boulot nous
travailler ça j'habite mort varient
chabot je bois du bon vin et j'écris
ouais alors vote libre est vraiment à
l'opposé de tous ses livres de la
rentrée qui sont plaints de mon propre
et d'air du temps dont on parle plus que
du vote finalement ça vous embête
je pense que je dis tiens puce la vérité
que tous les gens qui racontent des
nombrils a de quoi moi le nombril hadj
je n'y crois pas trop je pense que ça
fait partie de l'air du temps je pense y
ait des veaux d'or à petit peu partout
et puis vous savez ça dure ce que durent
le temps et ça passe les classes et ça
fait du bien d'entendre après cette
émission comme ça très agitée ça fait du
bien de vous écouter la musique
livre très bon j'ai trouvé très très dur
par moment et alors je vais dire déjà il
ya un aspect témoignages
j'ai tout laissé sur les j'appelle pas
ça une tournante s'appelle c'est un viol
collectif parce que c'est ce que c'est
et là c'est du réalisme
ensuite le fait qu'elle devienne une
serial killeuse là c'est plus de
l'imagination parce que des serial
killeuse si on n'a pas beaucoup et il ya
surtout le personnage du flic obèses et
désespéré qui cherche la vérité qui est
absolument mais bouleversant veut dire
que vous avez beaucoup d'humanité parce
que vous avez aussi beaucoup bourlingué
en vautrin d'abord votre père c'était
pas ça oui oui c'était un parcours pas
tout à fait conforme mon père était
médecin il avait une très belle voix
mais il n'avait qu'une envie c'est être
d'être artiste lyrique est jeune ça n'a
jamais abouti cette affaire là mais il
faisait convenablement les accouchements
et les versions et je voyais partir avec
sa 201 comme ça en leur aide je suis
dans l'arène il allait il allait
accoucher des femmes sur des péniches en
plein temps la neige c'est quelqu'un
d'assez assez formidable mais il était
malheureux il était malheureux il
tentait de se suicider de temps en temps
ils subissaient des électrochocs lui
cacher les percuteurs de sa de son
revolver il ya eu votre père ensuite
vous quitter auxerre pour paris vous
êtes premier hallyday xavier a pris le
7/12 parker et vous quitter tous pour
l'inde
oui hélas 21 ans vous faites un enfant
une indienne qui a prévu de travailler
avec rossellini sur son film qu'il a
fait là bas qui s'appelle india alors
pas une vie assez où j'ai beaucoup
voyagé dans la première partie de ma vie
j'habitais cinq ans en inde
sap et que je connais bien et là aussi
j'ai rencontré la tolérance mais manque
de bol j'ai 28 ans je suis revenue
puisque j'étais sursitaire et je me suis
retrouvé à faire la guerre d'algérie
vous étiez à reggane dans le sud
algérien voilà pour le pour les bombes
atomiques les juges et du public
français filmer la première bombe
atomique française quand j'étais au
service de ma déjà faire un flash
c'était beau ça non c'était beau mais c
était terrible vous savez ouais c'est à
dire que bon les quatre cavaliers de
l'apocalypse au passé au dessus de nos
têtes ce jour là alors autre expérience
effectivement qui vous a appris la vie
avec votre femme anne vous avez un
enfant autiste
un enfant qui criait jour et nuit qui
essayait de se mutiler qui cassent les
meubles et vous avez donc décidé
et habiter à la campagne c'était la
seule façon de faire et c'est ce qui
nous a obligé à changer de métier donc
c'est là que vous êtes devenu jean
vautrin après avoir été jean herment et
quand on vous dit c'est à cause de lui
que vous êtes partis là-bas faisait
cette phrase sublime visite non c'est
grâce à lui oui c'est grâce à lui c'est
vrai vous savez quand on est obligé
quand on est acculé
quand on est obligé de tirer un chariot
aussi lourd aussi aussi difficile qui
incriminent les êtres de toute une
famille les frères et soeurs et tout ça
on n'a pas le choix
et alors ou bien on s'en va c'est la
fuite ou bien on s'y attelle et à ce
moment là c'est ce qui nous est arrivé à
l'été comédienne elle était un donald
était bien connu à l'époque j'avais joué
au théâtre beaucoup est bon on a vécu
effectivement à la campagne dans une
grande maison de gosse pouvait exprimer
tout ce sont des arbres à tous son
désespoir
c'est vrai qu'il ya des jours où on a
envie de passer de l'autre côté de la
barrière parce que les ce que les murs
sont pleines virgule de merde et que la
vaisselle a été cassé plusieurs
plusieurs fois dans la semaine mais il
en ressort
il en ressort une nouvelle race d'hommes
c'est moi je suis plein d'énigmes et je
dis toujours que on peut être blessé
mais pas détruit quoi si on s'y met mais
mais se confronter à ce handicap et
l'autisme
c'est quelque chose que je ne souhaite à
personne puisque c'est sans espoir de
guérison
on ne peut qu'agir ça moyen terme on ne
peut qu'espérer d'étouffement agos fait
un jour la boucle du lacet la petite
boucle puis la grande boucle et puis un
jour il arrive à mettre ses chaussures
est ce jour là il peut se promener je
veux dire c'est plutôt ces progrès la
dont il s'agit merci d'avoir été avec
comme seuls six mois